the global response to russia's action
now include more sanctions that could
affect vladimir putin and family members
personally but some european countries
may also be helping russia fund the war
indirectly but they feel they have no
choice nancy cordes is at the white
house nancy good morning
good morning nate yeah there's
definitely a balancing act going on here
with treasury secretary janet yellen
warning that global prices for energy
food so many other goods are already on
the rise as a result of this war and
those prices could go even higher if the
world takes the obvious next step and
fully blocks russian oil and gas
president biden issued his latest salvo
wednesday in the financial war on russia
freezing any u.s related assets held by
russia's largest banks and sanctioning
the two grown daughters of russian
president vladimir putin i'm going to
sign an executive order that's going to
ban any new u.s investment in russia he
said the global sanctions imposed so far
will shrink russia's gdp by double
digits this year but russia's massive
energy industry is still largely
untouched you can't cut off his cash
flow
until you cut off his oil and gas expert
exports
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
urged world leaders to do just that
wednesday saying if there is no painful
package of sanctions no real supply of
necessary weapons that we have asked for
many times then russia will see it as
the permission to go further but
shutting off russia's oil spigot could
devastate european economies we continue
to assess how we can maximize the impact
while minimizing the impact on other
economies including of course
the global global oil marketplace
as for the weapons zelensky wants the
u.s secretary of state insisted
wednesday the world is already stepping
up between the united states and
other allies and partners we have
provided or will soon provide 10
anti-tank systems 10 for every single
russian tank
the u.n is expected to vote today on
whether to strip russia of its seat on
the u.n human rights council in response
to the horrifying images that we have
seen coming out of bucha of thousands of
innocent civilians being killed but
russia has rather ominously warned gail
that a yes vote by any nation is going
to be viewed as a quote
unfriendly gesture
all right nancy thank you very much